making his fourth start gooby's
two-on-one with a 2.08 era yeah fastball
90-94 just about 39 of his pitches
fastball way lower than his normal over
about 50 percent of his career slider
curve and change up so they have a two
out base runner there and matt chapman
who had a six rbi night last night
including a pair of homers will be the
next batter and that is in there a
breaking ball struck him out looking and
the inning is over so bundy does a good
job they fail to get that runner in from
third base mike fires coming off his
first one of the season his last start
that was against the texas rangers
identical score 6-4 against the angels
however he just went four innings in
that game six innings against the
rangers picked up the victory so the
baser loaded for pujols he was eight for
31 lifetime against the ace right-hander
with three homers swung on and missed on
a fast ball away and pull strikes out
and fires works out of it he has an
infield single grossman goes to second
and that'll bring up austin allen pitch
is chased and missed he got him on a
slider struck him out so one out of one
on here comes olson ride it out to first
base his first time up no score and the
next pitch it's bounced by the mound out
behind second stop by fletcher second
for one relay over to first and that is
in time a double play nicely turned
fletcher rendone
to albert so you don't see
too many of those that goes down to say
six
five three here comes the o2 hit in the
air and it's traveling out the right
center field that ball's carrying out in
right center field and out on the
warning track making the running catch
on that one is mike trout
he had goodwin in pursuit as well but
trout took charge there makes a nice
running grab for the first down mike
fires even armed without a very good
curveball has managed to retire seven
angels in order he gets random ohtani
and pujols four five and six that is
drilled out to left field the angels are
gonna have a one-nothing lead anthony
rendell with a big fly his third
brendon is getting hot four hits last
two games two home runs on base
six times in the last two nights for
anthony brendon so here's castro the
angel is hoping to get some more here in
the sitting castro hits one out toward
left center field this one chasing ramon
loriano back to the wall gone big fly
for jason castro a three-run jack and
it's four nothing angels angels are
playing long ball in the inning it's a
three-run shot goodwin will be the next
hitter and here's the next pitch this is
lifted high in the air and this ball is
carrying deep out into right center
field it is out of here
three times in the inning the angels
have hallmark
rendon castro and now goodwin it's five
nothing angels
yellow bundy is dealt tonight eight
strikeouts one walk four hits allowed
chabot strikes out two down twice now
one swinging once looking mark canna
steps to play with two outs popped up
foul first base side albert is running
after it so is the catcher castro albert
will make the call and catch so bundy
after hitting the first batter got the
next three easily in fact they did not
even get the ball in play here's david
fletcher who's had an o for three night
he's trying to keep his hitting streak
alive he's hit the ball hard a couple
times tonight but nothing to show for
he'll hit one out toward the corner and
left field robbie grossman getting ready
get your dancing shoes on gooby big fly
david fletcher boy the angels are
knocking it out of the ballpark again
tonight the fourth home run for the
angels and four last night against
oakland pitching and the lead grows it's
now six nothing
two outs tony kemp will be the batter
struck him out and the inning is over
so bundy's night is likely over that's
his tenth strikeout in this ball game so
here's trout he's one for four at a base
hit in the sixth inning fastball fly
ball right field toward the line a long
run in the corner and it's gonna be
going over the wall and draping himself
and pinder makes an unbelievable catch
he went
across the foul line deep in the right
field corner and then draping himself
and reaching into the stand suspended on
top of the short wall
the side wall over there makes an
unbelievable catch and a full out race
took one look to see where he was and he
was going down up over in
on the other side of the wall into the
stands to make that play
i'll remember that yeah hanzo robles
takes over here in the ninth inning to
try to uh close out the victory
angel's up six to nothing
like i said last time out he really
threw the ball well this is his seventh
ballgame on one he's giving up 900 runs
in five in the third davis tonight oh
for three two fly ball outs
davis chops this one over to third
rendon's got it he'll go to second base
light that baby up as the angels make it
two in a row against the athletics
tonight they shut him out six to nothing
the hottest team in baseball coming in
to this series the angels have won two
in a row scoring 16 runs eight home runs